[Music]
my next guest appeared on scrubs now she
plays shelly the daycare teacher on
raising hope here's a clip of her in
action take a look
rusty
sometimes
things can make you sad
sometimes
things can make you mad
you might be feeling mangy or your
diapers might be changing or your diaper
might need changing
i don't know
but whatever it is it's got you grumpy a
thorn in your paw or a great big dumpy
you need to stay calm and follow my
golden rule
don't fight
please you know i've wanted to talk to
you for a while uh and i'm so glad that
you're here and i sort of wanted to find
out about you first of all like for
example you you consider yourself a
country girl is that right which i
didn't i didn't know that it was true
but yeah kinda i mean i grew up in what
i thought was the country because i well
i was born in new jersey but then when i
was eight we moved to pennsylvania oh
yeah new jersey's not the country
um it's a nice state though it gets a
bad rap but it's a nice state um but
yeah
you moved to pennsylvania yeah to
nazareth pennsylvania where there really
isn't much happening oh you're from
nazareth
all right um but no uh there's like a
lot of fields and i thought oh i'm gonna
be a country girl i was eight i made my
mom buy me a corn cob pipe and uh i
would like walk around the yard like hey
i'm huck finn you know
but
but nobody has a corn no one smoked a
corn cob pipe in like 200 years no but
oddly they sold them at the bagel smith
in new jersey
so we bought them and then moved to
pennsylvania did you have any do any
country stuff did you go hunting oh yeah
my dad hunts oh he hunts okay yeah he's
killed a lot of things um
but uh but mostly one day he killed two
deer a girl deer and a boy deer on the
same day oh i know i felt really bad for
both of them but i wrote a letter to the
deer in pennsylvania to stay away from
my dad or he will kill them
it's called deer deer
now what bothered you about the boy and
the girl on the same day like maybe
we're on a date you know and then
now they're hanging up at our house
they're together
they look happy now in that clip you
were playing the ukulele was that the
first instrument that you picked up have
you always been musical oh well i've
always played instruments i played the
piano since i was four and then uh when
i was nine they uh the band director
came to school and they let you pick an
instrument and
he played like you know all the
different instruments and then the
trombone he played the trombone and i
was like oh man everybody's going to
pick the trombone that's like clearly
the coolest one
but it was only me and this kid ryan
that picked trump and everybody else
picked like saxophone or drums or
something like yeah i i played trombone
i haven't played in the marching band
but i wasn't very good so i would just
kind of like move my slide like
pretending you know it's an easy
instrument to fake you don't even have
to really know it i knew
you don't have to
just
you're having a bad day you're just like
whatever you know
just move your arm around sure
now you do a speaking music you do a
monthly musical show tell us what is
well tell us about this show what's it
called um well it's at the steve allen
theater and it's called playing with
micucci
that's my name
your name your name of course makuchi
you weren't trying to to be uh you know
no that's the dirtiest part of the whole
show yeah i mean like there's cookies
and puppets it's really clean except for
the title but but i didn't know what
kuchi meant for so long like i i was
like 25 years old reading the vagina
monologues and i was like what like
wait so this was your last name and you
didn't know no and then so all the times
the kids had made fun of me i had no
idea what they were talking about it was
like i had this flashlight
like all the times kids made fun of me
like
like if we have a kid we should like
name him phil
like
or like
pat
or sharon okay
[Applause]